hi all this is tammy Clark I'm Nikki
Micucci Oh Miley Turner here it's the
music so loud we are here we're live at
VidCon which is apparently some
convention for the young kids we decided
we're gonna go interview some people why
not let's have fun we've got a
splendiferous Lee if I could use that
can you spell splinter firstly SPL en
dia PR 0 usly I'm impressed in a world
of youtubers 3 miles looking for their
sons who love coupons Connor if you
could give any kids advice what would
you tell them to do don't go to college
and just make a youtube videos do you
watch internet videos for the boobs in
the butt uh not on the youtubes they
wonder if there's gonna be a dance party
you know I hope there aren't any drugs
here well that's how you know if you're
doing good parenting you know if your
kids don't do the drugs VidCon itself
thing with everything no I'm sure you
know I'm from a bad his muscles are real
big you are we invited to the gun show
can we see the gun show
but I do want to see the gun show one
more time just a final touch through the
skin the gun show naked or clouds on Oh
naked are you here to see you anybody
you're just here to support your
daughters no just them I don't know
anybody here you don't know anything on
youtube at all know what do you do with
your time I play golf Connor Connor you
guys do those prank videos on each other
what has kept you all together even
though you keep being mean to each other
love love is it dangerous here shouldn't
we make up YouTube man like an alter ego
character like do you guys must have
alter egos sit away oh I do I'm kind of
like Beyonce she's got the stash if he
is so maybe your nick name is Nick you
don't say it's been a great day here at
VidCon thank you to NMR hmm ok think I
kicking everyone out I think they're
kicking everyone out of here but I just
wanted to say I'm so excited to be here
it's my first youtube convention i'm
going to start checking out more of
these videos on the internet please and
YouTube us is that what is that a thing
youtube on i think if you you sign up
for youtube and then you message people
i think that's how it works we should
get some drinks oh yeah yeah yeah
oh oh oh god there was a quake oh my god
I think it comes quick yeah